be brutally honest being honest you got
to get honest honestly the most honesty
not really honest to be honest to be
honest brutal honesty
hello believe nation today we're gonna
talk about how you can be brutally
honest one of the big things that all
startups do is they lie to themselves
over and over and over minds faster
minds cheaper mine's better minds this
Minds that no it's not and the reason
it's not is because whoever it is you're
competing with it's not like they're
ignoring you it's not like oh my
goodness this guy just started on
Shopify in the startup competition he's
doing a million dollars this year what
was me I might as well close up the
doors what are they doing I'm gonna copy
what they're doing and now you've got to
stay ahead and so you know you've got to
be very careful as an entrepreneur to be
brutally honest with yourself and those
are some of the things that you'll hear
from me as a mentor that you know know
what you know know what you don't know
but you've got to know your business
better than anybody you know you did a
very successful sitcom you then came out
and then it was cancelled that's just
this show sort of safe duty thinking
away I think what saved me is me being
honest and I think I somehow had the
courage to do something and say
something that I knew would would
possibly in my career and instead of
making business more important
I made my soul and my my life more
important and I think by by being
truthful and by being honest that saved
me and then I was given the opportunity
to do something where I could actually
just be myself and people can see who I
am and if they respond to it great and
if they don't great and they've
responded the only thing that stops you
from getting what you want in life is
the bold story you tell yourself of why
you can't have it get that what stops
you back is the story because the story
stops you from getting honest and if you
can't get honest with yourself there's
no way you can go what made you like
this success in sales in life it's like
a road map right you know where you want
to go
and you have this perfect strategy the
straight line to get there it's a
perfect strategy it's gonna get you
there every single time but if you don't
know your starting point if you're not
getting eyes where you actually are it
doesn't matter how powerful the strategy
is and it doesn't matter how powerful
your goal is I'm gonna actually set a
goal today write a 60 day goal and let's
say you really set this goal and I'll
show you how to do it in a brilliant way
so it's visceral so it makes you really
feel it you see it you sense it you
smell a goal that's step one I'm gonna
teach you the straight line which is
your strategy to get to your goal but if
you're not honest with where you all
right now your starting point the map is
worthless
there's three things that you need to
know where you are where you want to go
and how you're gonna get there those are
the three things you must have to take
advantage of any opportunity I'm gonna
give you the strategy I'm gonna actually
tell me exactly where you want to go for
yourself you got to get honest don't
blame the boss don't blame the leaves
don't blame your job don't blame the
industry are in just get out if you
don't like your industry find another
one man in the mirror that's my favorite
song
I tend the whole by feeling that no
matter what you do in the world it
really has to start with you it is my
philosophy too if you want to make the
world a better place take a look at
yourself and then make a change
before you do yeah well people don't
look at themselves honestly they don't
look at themselves and point the finger
and it's always the other guys fought or
somebody up that he should change
yourself
look at yourself make better of yourself
what a comedian such complex people I
think that's just that weird thing of
what drives you to do it you know it's
that weird thing of why would you get
out on stage and talk about things and
my favorite comedians that I've ever
seen well is the most honest like friar
you know prior I would be talking about
dying and making it funny and though the
recent kind of embodying boddyhm end of
that is Chris Rock doesn't he
louis c.k does talks about really
painful things but he's just talking
about his life and but and the idea of
going on staging and I'm gonna talk
about really painful things but let's
see if you'd relate to it and they're
complex because it's that what I think
it's a survival mechanism you know
sometimes I did it because it's the one
way to get laid sometimes I did it
because it was over it's an outlet it's
you know cheaper than and cheaper than
therapy and in a weird way they said it
said the things that these things in us
you know spinning inside them that they
have to talk about and it depends on
which way you do it then you know well
what drives an honest intention is
always at the core no usually at the
core of a worldly business success and
in essence I want to get people
something they need hopefully you're
giving something to need that you
approve of you know if you're vegan and
don't have a steak house you know
something like that but but it's a idea
of going to work and giving people
something that you believe in and and
and making an honest intention more so
that that you give without you know so
much it's not about the expectation of
receiving so much it there's faith in
this idea that if you put your energy
into something it will give you a return
but it is something greater about loving
something enough to just want to share
it and I think that that's a major
motivation and we all should have
someone happiness and success I think
customers want to be talked to and not
talked to at and I think a lot of
companies talk at a customer and it's
very sort of glossy speed
and it doesn't seem real and from day
one I just I never tried to hide that I
was the girl in my apartment with the
red backpack it's like this is Who I am
and I find that people end up rooting
for you and opening more doors if you're
really honest early on some people start
businesses and try to come across that
they're much bigger than they are
because they feel like that's the only
way they're gonna be taken seriously but
if you know your products great and you
know why you made it you don't have to
apologize for being out of your home or
your apartment or being small there's
this layer of transparency right it's
like the great entrepreneurs that I love
the most is like there's not there's not
a bill be honest about everything and
they'll tell you exactly how it is good
or bad and we'll just put a stake in the
ground on an opinion but not drive it
home and it's it's like that's the stuff
I respect the most
then what's your advice to these small
business founders today we're card
you're gonna need some luck with the
harder you work the luckier you get and
if it doesn't work out that's not the
end of the world I just don't have
anything in common with people that sit
there and say oh my god it was terrible
so yeah it's over it's water over the
dam under the bridge get on with it and
start another business the next day or
another career and be honest look in a
mirror and say why didn't it work out
well it wasn't the skill set or it
wasn't I didn't have the temperament for
it or I was in the wrong place wrong
time maybe I can afford to do it again
maybe I can't but people aren't honest
with themselves they what I've always
done is I've taken a yellow pad I draw a
line down the middle write out the pros
on one side the cons on another in a
sense that if I let you see it you
wouldn't laugh at me and then when I get
done I just rip it up and throw it away
because I've worked out in my mind what
is real and what isn't and what I can
present to people and what I can't we
put this sort of slogan I prefer brutal
honesty to hypocritical politeness on
our website because it's a really
disservice to people you don't have to
be offensive to be honest when I don't
like somebody I can't get offensive too
but generally you can be constructive
and very honest and I preferred that
brutal honesty because it serves a
purpose the receiver can do something
about it if it's a constructive
criticism if you get poor the
hypocritical politeness you might lose a
lot so again it's about having enough
confidence to say the other person will
eventually appreciate it and that's loga
good slogan came after I was working on
a company with another major venture
firm and I didn't believe their plan
would work
they had 45 50 million dollars in the
bank account so everybody was
comfortable - comfortable my view I
talked to the founders why it wouldn't
work what my concerns were the other VCS
agreed with me in the board meeting said
all these polite things you know so 40
engineers wasted three or four years of
their life because nobody was willing to
tell them the honest truth about what
they really thought all right and I
swore I would never let anybody wish
their life at least give them the best
advice I had to give and tell them I may
be wrong but I'm not gonna say something
I don't believe in I just want in and
that's extremely valuable to the other
thing but to be honest
look there are situations you keep it
offends people and I offend people often
but it helps them if they're really
introspective that's founder by the way
in that company called me four years
later after after this company this
company got sold for three million
dollars for three and a half four years
later sad story and he called me a year
after that said I only want to work with
you on my next venture because I wish
somebody had told me thank you guys so
much for watching I'd love to know which
of the clips meant the most to you what
impact that's going to have on your
business and why leaving the comments
below and I'll join in this guy
I also want to give a quick shadow to
Zaino new in-house jano new and Ashe new
in has new one has Zen oh thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book it
really means a lot to me for you guys if
you want your chance at a shadow in the
future video make sure to pick up a copy
of the book and send in your receipt so
we can keep track thank you guys so much
for watching and continue to believe
whatever your one where it is and I'll
see you soon